encourage women
and Kerry Wood
I thought of it as to you know whether
or not you are an artist or not that
doesn't really need to be a spark it's
just kind of something that's there that
you can't get rid of you know and and to
a large degree we're doing something
that's really kind of impractical to be
kind you know and so dumb and otherwise
an irrational in other ways but you've
driven to do it and you don't know why
you know I I was a practical person i
went into pharmacy at an early age to
really decided to go into pharmacy and
even though we were building the star
trek side and making an eight-millimeter
film and never really occurred to me at
that age then this could be a career
option so it seems like you you may
maybe you blast them a little bit later
in life so what was it that kind of drew
you towards film well basically I think
it was that the interest didn't go away
you know I mean I had I had that
interest early on we spent a year doing
that I mean you know all our friends
were off doing other things and we're
locked in the basement building this
floor to ceiling set and you know most
people don't do that and you know I went
off to college to do something practical
something that would earn a good living
and but all that time I had an interest
in it and even in pharmacy school went
into it they had a studio underneath the
pharmacy school at SC and they would do
a weekly in-house news show and I
immediately gravitated to that started
doing camera on that getting into the
studio and editing and writing and I'm
thinking this is more fun than pharmacy
was at that point you didn't attend the
film school at USC never went to film
school didn't go to the actual film now
now so the knowledge has been really
groomed over over many years